I think the fact that you did win an Oscar, Marlee,
really did pave the way.
One of the things that I have such a deep respect for
is how the film treats the viewer
as if they're just watching a family.
Exactly.
There are so many levels in this film.
It's not just for deaf people
or it's not about just deaf people.
It's for everyone.
And, and it does include deaf people.
It does include deaf culture.
It includes sign language,
but people who just happen to be deaf
it's sport of the story.
We're human beings, just like anybody else.
We're working class people.
We earn living.
We're trying to be parents.
We're, you know, we have kids.
There are so many things that happen in this film
that you'll recognize, that you can identify with.
There's singing,
there's deaf culture,
there's fishing
there's parenting,
it's all in one package in this film.
And it's such a good film
that people really love watching it from what I've seen.
You know, again, going back to Hollywood,
we're grateful for Vendôme and Pathé
who put trust in our direction
and put it in Sian Heder's hands as the director and writer
to use authentic deaf actors, to tell this story.
And for Apple TV+ to pick it up
right after Sundance winning four awards,
which is unprecedented
for people to see and believe in us,
really feels validating.
It was a movie that everybody should see.
It was a--
And all the love that we got.
It was a giant success at Sundance.
It was bought for $25 million, an unprecedented amount.
There you go, it's funny.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
I was looking at Sundance
to see if anyone beat our record, not yet.
You know, I don't need to brag, but I feel good.
I've been waiting for someone to beat us.
Well and just like Marlee mentioned,
so our producers from Pathé and Vendôme,
I feel like that group of folks planted a seed
and that seed blossomed
from this French film, which started to bloom
and become stronger and stronger
into a beautiful apple tree.
A tree fell down, apple fell off that tree
and down the hill like a snowball effect
just plowing into Hollywood with deaf talent.
(audience cheering)
And for them, for the producers to hire us
three actors who are deaf, authentic deaf,
to carry a film, it's unprecedented, as I said
it's never been done before.
It is so rare.
And your children are CODAs
Four.
And your daughter?
I have a daughter, yes who is a CODA.
Right now we have two interpreters here
who actually CODAs themselves believe it or not.
And so that's, my daughter's a CODA.
Her daughter is a CODA.
And so thank you for sharing this conversation
and bridging two worlds between the hearing and deaf world.
It's so important.
And for so many CODAs who are younger
who have hearing friends
they really struggle to understand them.
And that's why increasing this awareness
with young people,
they can become more accepting.
(upbeat music)